ce sera finalement la médaille d'argent
pour patrice delaveau le cavalier de bas
normand a terminé deuxième de cette
terrible finale à quatre la finale du
concours de saut d'obstacles de ces jeux
équestres mondiaux vous voyez à
l'instant direct patrice delaveau monte
sur la deuxième marche du podium
médaille d'argent il est ovationné par
le stade d'ornano en mille personnes qui
l'ont soutenu
toute cette semaine et par fièrement
aujourd'hui dans cette terrible finale à
quatre quel suspense et spectacles
bonjour à tous la médaille d'or 1 de ce
concours de sauts d'obstacles de ces jo
ducasse mondiaux à robien au néerlandais
jérôme and the bold and on va sur ses
images de patrice delaveau heureux une
médaille d'argent c'est quand même
formidable
il a fallu 43 centièmes 43 centièmes
anthony la jouer différence mais on peut
être fier très fier de patrice delaveau
qui a tout donné il nous a fait 4
merveilleux parcours sans faute sur
cette finale à quatre ça s'est joué à
grand chose on va en parler on va revoir
tout ça dans cette émission dans un
instant mais on vous laisse vivre ces
images en direct du stade d'ornano c'est
en ce moment à trice de la voix clamé
par ce stade il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de tension et d'émotion aussi
tout à l'heure devant un magnifique
moment
patrice delaveau souriant et son cheval
orient-express cheval bas-normands aussi
diarra découdre est orienté passe qui
lui aussi n'a pas failli dans ses
épreuves et voilà le premier
gérone the ball dames le néerlandais
médaille d'or de ces jeux équestres
mondiaux ville et les supporters
néerlandais qui sont là aussi un présent
dans le stade en thaïlande chaudron il a
fait très chaud aujourd'hui il y avait
beaucoup de tension
c'était vraiment un grand grand moment
de sport on a vibré un tout ce talent à
lundi en regardant ça
le félicite la présidente de la
fédération casse international dont le
mandat un touche à sa fin formidable joe
and the ball dames et son cheval zénith
le fils n'ont pas failli il fallait
avoir les nerfs solides
il est passé juste après patrice
delaveau sur la finale à 4 tout à
l'heure et il n'a pas failli
très fort un les néerlandais puisqu'ils
ont gagné aussi l'or par équipes en saut
d'obstacles tout le monde est debout de
ce tas d'ornano plein comme un oeuf cet
après midi
on voulait vivre encore quelques
secondes ces images le clou du spectacle
ou de ces jeux équestres mondiaux en
normandie
mala bonjour à tous bonjour à tous très
heureux de vous retrouver on a passé un
après-midi incroyable oui oui c'est vrai
qu'on était arrivé aux télévisions à
suivre cette terrible finale à 4 ou
vraiment il ya du suspense jusqu'au bout
de regarder le dessin de shaun hill pas
si ma normand que ça effectivement oui
bas-normands du tout mais là bas mais en
même temps pas de normes ont alors
reconnu a fait regarde un tout étonné
que les retours de patrice delaveau et
mais j'ai choisi ne jetez pas le tour
le tout regarder le tour où tout s'est
joué c'est le troisième pour patrice
delaveau
il est alors turc kazakh à ce que le
cheval du suédois bengston un tour crée
très maîtrisée patrice delaveau
concentré c'est un cheval difficile
c est lui qui a causé le plus de mains
ils sont tous cet été par les deux
principaux concurrents avec ce cheval
alors patrice d'aller le voir ne va pas
faire tomber deux barres commence comme
à son habitude ils travaillent tous ces
obstacles
chaque à bord avec ce cheval qu'il ne
connaît pas il a pu sauter trois fois
avec lui
la détente pour apprendre à le connaître
ce sont les règles de la finale à capter
très très court pour trouver les boutons
du cheval
aucune faute grande attention à ce
moment-là de cet après midi au stade
d'ornano jusque
dans cette dernière ligne ces deux
derniers obstacles
c'est très serré et puis le dernier
obstacle un oxer sans faute mais hélas
mais avant de pénalité nous avons
dépassé le temps imparti et c'est ce qui
va faire éditer en sa différence 43
centièmes de seconde
voilà ce qui les fait perdre la médaille
d'or 43 centièmes de seconde
et vous voyez le camp français compte en
ce moment là mais un peu tendu car on
sait que hélas la médaille d'or n'est
pas gagner et on va écouter
patrice delaveau il ya quelques instants
je les ai sentis en fin de parcours j'ai
appelé le cheval très bien avec moi et
j'ai bien senti que j'étais pas
suffisamment vite mais j'ai préféré ne
pas l'ouvrir mais en tant pis je vais
risques et de peut-être un petit
dépassement de temps mais mais pas une
faute et quand j'ai réagi j'avais déjà
passé j'avais déjà passé le canyon 53
foulée j'ai un petit peu tard maintenant
c'est une petite faute technique à celui
qu'ils écoutent la médaille d'or mais il
a quand même la médaille d'argent
patrice delaveau
merci emmanuel on va venir
avec florent turpin tenir way fol
après-midi
oui scénario absolument hallucinant
regardez c'est l'un des moments forts de
cette compétition cette finale à quatre
qui n'existe que lors des jeux équestres
mondiaux
c'est d'abord devant 20000 spectateurs
que le bas-normand patrice delaveau fait
son entrée dans ce stade d'ornano tout
comme ses trois adversaires
un hollandais un suédois et une
américaine quatre cavaliers quatre
chevaux de très haut niveau qui vont
disputer cette finale tournante et
déroutante tous les compteurs sont remis
à zéro et ça débute de manière plutôt
classique puisque chaque cavalier assure
le premier passage sur son cheval et ça
commence très bien pour patrice delaveau
sur orient-express mais aussi pour
l'américaine maldonne et le hollandais
du belle dame qui réalise aussi des
passages sans faute en revanche le
suédois ericsson en bas à gauche de
l'image comme et lui la première erreur
et erreur et c'est ensuite que tout se
complique regarder scénario hallucinant
les cavaliers échangent leurs chevaux
pour effectuer les trois autres passages
final ça paraît fou d'autant qu'ils
n'ont que quelques secondes
d'échauffement pour maîtriser leur
nouvelle monture
même à ce niveau là tout est possible la
preuve
seul le calvadosien patrice delaveau et
le hollandais du belles dames vont
réaliser des parcours parfait lors des
deuxième et troisième passage
l'américaine et le suédois sont déjà
hors jeu
tout va donc se jouer entre le français
et le néerlandais lors de l'ultime
passage le stade d'ornano retient son
souffle
on l'a vue sans trembler la prise de la
ville en dise encore un sans faute
c'est incroyable avant d'assister en
spectateur à l'ultime passage de son
adversaire en espérant bien sûr qu'ils
fassent tomber une barre ça c'est
vraiment j'ai joué à rien vous le voyez
malgré cette petite touchette le
hollandais ne va pas commettre d'erreurs
hamdi belle dame qui n'en portent à la
faveur d'un meilleur chrono petite
déception évidemment pour patrice
delaveau qui doivent se contenter de
cette médaille d'argent dans ces jeux
équestres mondiaux chez lui en normandie
quel après midi alain talons vous êtes
notre consultant vous avez avec nous
toute cette quinzaine vous êtes auteur
de livres vous êtes hypo maniaque et on
m'a dit que vous aviez la larme à l'oeil
tout à l'heure oui c'était c'était très
émouvant d'être à nouveau dans
l'enceinte dans cette arène et d'avoir
participé à cette finale à quatre il ya
en fin de compte 2,2 activités sportives
en une c'est le traditionnel tour des
cavaliers sur les obstacles très beau
par ailleurs et puis le fait de
découvrir en trois minutes
des chevaux qui sont très forts très
puissant parfois nerveux mais aussi
fatigué par les quatre jours de
compétition il faut les découvrir et
pouvoir en trouver une communion en
quelques secondes ça fait très émouvant
aussi quelques valeurs orient-express 1
cet après midi encore c'est un cheval
extraordinaire âge pas vraiment ouais
lara de la jce notre y est née chez
patrice bourouis aux confins de la
théorie de dlc vraiment là et qu'elle va
non seulement voilà au coeur d'or au
berceau du cheval de sport c'est le
français
ce qui est aussi très émouvant non point
de vue c'est que j'ai pu suivre la jeune
carla carrière de jeune cheval d'orgueil
express qui était monté par par des gens
dont parle pas souvent finalement
monsieur tirard qui était formateur de
jeunes chevaux
je vais le voir sur différents concours
elle regarde les ronces et le tour
d'honneur à deux des trois cavaliers
médaille d'or médaille d'argent médaille
de bronze
regardez un peu à tout le monde et 2
brustad relaciones les trois meilleurs
cavaliers mondiaux dont le bas-normand
patrice delaveau il n'a pas eu sa
médaille d'or mais les quand même
deuxième et ils avaient envie de la
disputer cette finale à quatre mains il
l'a fait chez lui quel parcours de cette
semaine un public regardez ordinaire
quelle ambiance sur ce stade quelques
clous de spectacle pour ces jeux
équestres mondiaux on pouvait
difficilement imaginer mieux quand même
hein bah oui c'était quand même le rêve
on est ardu patrice delaveau il ya une
semaine dans cette émission abidi donc
on ne sait pas bien sûr souhaité qu'il
aille jusque là ben voilà il y est allé
il a disputé sept miracles qu'il avait
vraiment très envie c'est quelqu'un de
ta joueurs en communiante exploite son
jeu va passer de labo il a envie il a un
self control énorme
et lui qui est ici rapide au rang de
général pour les des barrages je vais
souvent premier titre et on va peut-être
aller rejoindre corinne bien rosa qui
est au stade d'ornano et je crois que
corinne vous êtes en compagnie des
propriétaires d'orienter qu spatiale
ambiance derrière voix il ya un super
ambiance hier le tour d'honneur est
vraiment on souligne le fair play du
public français et donc je suis avec
monsieur madame paieront pas qu'ils sont
donc les propriétaires du cheval de
patrice delaveau les talons
orient-express vous avez vibré jusqu'au
bout pour pour patrice et aussi pour
votre votre cheval ah oui c'était
extraordinaire
temps ci c'est rien du tout mais écoutez
si on nous avait demandé de signer pour
cette médaille d'argent n'en racing
aimerait bien on commençait même c'est
extraordinaire superbe quand même
impérial sous la monte des autres
cavaliers écoutez moi je trouve
extraordinaire un jeu après c'est des
petites fautes de cavaliers
qui connaissent pas de tu vas mais le
cheval on a vraiment encore son pied de
près vous avez vibré aussi on vous a vu
très très concentré pendant les pannes
les pattes des parcours de patrice et du
chevalement rire la vie en vidéo d'un
sans faute bête et on avait aussi envie
de 200 photos riant et je pense que le
cheval était absolument la gestion eux
il a aujourd'hui montré ce qu'ils
savaient faire il termine sur un
parcours formidable il est encore dix
ans après une semaine caminade tpe et
oui vraiment il usa qui nous a encore
étonné encore aujourd'hui encore de
belles années devant lui ce cheval
ah oui mais pas prêt de la clape à tout
de suite on l'attendait plus loin il a
droit à un repos bien mérité non monde
dans les paddocks et après oui
effectivement c'est un chemin que vous
allez en voir
j'espère beaucoup et et il est vraiment
talentueux en a pas un problème non plus
vraiment électro d'une heure merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci il ya
l'ambiance corinne sur ce stade on voit
les images cependant on va envoyer les
images pendant vous étiez en direct avec
nous et je donne des bonnes vivre un peu
peut-être encore quelques secondes c'est
cette ambiance vous qui êtes dans le
show corinne c'est vrai que c'est une
ambiance extraordinaire répète passé et
on peut être un petit peu chauvin à tout
le monde dit qu'il ya une bien meilleure
ambiance qu à lexington ya quatre ans
donc on le dit quand même on n'est pas
les seuls à le dire et c'est vrai que
tout le monde a respecté aussi y avait
aussi beaucoup de respect quand les
autres cavaliers sont peints sont
passées mais on sent république
également de connaisseurs ici ici dans
ce stade de caen alors allons tenter un
petit peu de bol d'âme parce qu'antoine
examens et des supports patrice mais
quel champion au gérante de ball dames
le cabinet néerlandais qui était donc
champion du monde par équipes jeudi ici
il a été également en 2006 champion
olympique à sydney en 2000 il a cité à
trouver de très bons chevaux et pouvoir
très rapidement les formes et les mettre
à sa main pour pouvoir disputer les
épreuves les plus difficiles on encore
vu la preuve ces derniers jours à caen
c'était pas gagné et que son cheval de
belles dames parce qu'il a très peu
d'expérience un regardez regardez
corinne on va retourner parce que quand
vous êtes avec patrice delaveau
non vous avoue tout de suite une
fabuleuse semaine deux médailles en
argent
comment vous sentez là maintenant tout
de suite là pour à vrai dire je suis un
petit peu partagé entre la déception la
joie parce que je suis à deuxième j'ai
fait un tout petit point de dépassement
de temps rien du tout une foule et a
cessé de foule et c'est de fouler voir
une foule et c'est rien du tout
maintenant j'ai peut-être aussi éviter
une faute si la bombe ce qui aurait été
la même chose
d'un autre côté pour les chevaux c'est
pas plus mal on a évité encore un
parcours
bon voilà maintenant on fait on finit
cette semaine l'équipe de france
s'avèrent en ramenant deux médailles
d'argent
chez nous c'est quand même en ont réussi
à faire un championnat fantastique quand
même dans votre public vous l'avez
ressenti ce public tout au long de cette
semaine
oui nous ont vraiment poussé tout au
long de la semaine tous les cavaliers
français ainsi que aussi beaucoup de
cavaliers étrangers c'est un public
fantastique mais ça on le savait avant
le début de la compétition parce que
c'est un public vraiment de connaisseurs
je suis sûr qu'à qui a au moins 70% de
genre à la tribune qui est ce ton élevé
ou qui monte même à cheval et je dois
dire qu'on leur en fait tout au long de
la semaine un spectacle fantastique je
pense qu'on a été à la hauteur de
l'ordre de leur chaleur merci en tout
cas merci beaucoup et bravo patrice un
grand merci et bravo du ctma patrice
delaveau alain talons la normandie
vraiment terre de cheval là ça y est on
a tous les galons terre de naisseurs
terre d'éleveurs tire de champion
effectivement comme l'a dit emily blunt
express est né aux confins de la manche
le calvados
puis a été confiée rapidement à des gens
très connaisseurs les cheveux nu dans le
calvados qui ont valorisé à son rythme
orient-express qu'était un cheval est
extrêmement doué en tant que jeune
cheval pour ensuite effectivement le
confier aux europe et rompent est pour
pour participer aux épreuves les plus
difficiles très haut niveau
entièrement une une expérience humaine
de gens qui sont appris à se connaître
et qui vivent du cheval en normandie ça
c'est une très belle histoire et qui se
connaissent très bien
si on écoutait ce que disait eric
n'allait sûrement dit la procédure on
avoue aussi emmanuel hermand paître les
patrons les propriétaires n'être pas
trop si comme ça je n'avais nous a parlé
un de patrice delaveau de son enfance et
de l'enfance est le seul à nier a gagné
l'or par équipes et l'or individuel aux
premiers jeux équestres mondiaux de
stockholm en 90 quand même le souligner
est donc écouter ce qu'ils nous disaient
de patrice delaveau c'était très
émouvant ce dès ce midi patrice il a
beaucoup de sang froid il est énormément
d'expérience il a évidemment une super
technique sinon il en serait pas là
mais ce qui là aussi c
beaucoup d'instinct et beaucoup de
talent joue à lille j'ai une petite
anecdote si j'ai le temps alicia levy
je me souviens de patrice quand il a
débarqué avec son père robert donc
robert était un cadre complet concours
complet et je me souviens de patrice qui
arrive tout petit va voir 12 ans sur les
concours sur les concours hippiques avec
son père il était minuscule patrice et
puis il montait un cheval énorme qui
était un trotteur qui s'appelait
étendard du nord je me souviens encore
de son nom et c'était vraiment la puce
sur l'éléphant mais quand j'ai vu ce
petit gamin sur ce grand cheval qui
gagne et les épreuves avec un sens inouï
du galop des trajectoires des distances
etc
je me suis dit ce petit là il ira loin
de le voir aujourd'hui ici ça m'en donne
la chair de poule
sp sont dans le dos et je suis super
content quoi il nous a donné des
frissons à la piste sur l'éléphant
devenir un grand monsieur un très grand
cavalier alors dans quelques instants
stade d'ornano ce sera la cérémonie de
clôture de ces jeux équestres mondiaux
on va la vivre ensemble sur cette
antenne mais avant cela et bien on va
regarder un petit bilan rétrospectif de
cette de cette quinzaine de jeux
équestres mondiaux des choses s'est
passé beaucoup de choses
on a compilé les meilleures images on
regarde ça et après eh bien on va vivre
ensemble la cérémonie de clôture de ces
jeux équestres pour buriné 2014 en
normandie et ses furies débat qui nous a
préparé ça regardez
tout
une quinzaine riche en sensations en
émotions en péripéties ces jeux
équestres mondiaux resteront gravées
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire
au programme des réjouissances les
caprices du ciel ont empoisonné le début
des compétitions
un vrai déluge qui n'a pas réussi à
faire vaciller la couronne britannique
en dressage charlotte du jardin et son
champion va les gros ont ouvert les
festivités et les anglais sont sans
conteste les rois de ces jeux
premier au classement avec 15 médailles
dont 7 en or
chills pour un autre royaume celui des
pays bas qui n'est pas passé inaperçu en
par un stage avec 10 médailles de toutes
les couleurs et la france dans tout ça
elle a récolté sa médaille la plus
éclatante en voltige l'or pour ferrari
mais aussi l'argent pour andréani et le
bronze par équipes
pour lui pas de médaille mais beaucoup
d'émotion rodolphe cher cavaliers de
concours complet rendait hommage à son
père décédé la veille de la compétition
soit sûrement peut-être pu aller plus
vite mais je suis un peu en hausse à g
mais je voulais dans le stade dimanche
parce que mon papa me regarder et je
veuille à dimanche les jeux équestres
mondiaux c'est avant tout un hommage au
cheval alors qu'août chapeau à aucun
nouveau cheval né et élevé en basse
normandie
le champion du molay-littry doublement
consacré sous la selle de l'allemande
sandra parts médaillé d'or du concours
complet en individuel et par équipes
autre star de ces jeux la baie du
mont-saint-michel site d'exception qui a
accueilli l'épreuve d'endurance
encore une réussite pour les français
qui concerne leur médaille d'argent par
équipe
juste derrière l'espagne une belle
course qui n'a pas empêché la critique
parcours jugé trop difficile et très
éprouvant entraîné de nombreuses chutes
une compétition qui sera aussi témoin
d'un accident dramatique avec la mort
d'un cheval du costa rica
sur le cross c'est l'angleterre qui
perdra ou white zone
ce cheval de 13 ans décédera d'un arrêt
cardiaque juste après la ligne d'arrivée
la série noire s'est heureusement
arrêter là car des chutes il y en a eu
impressionnante mais ici sans
conséquence
pendant cette quinzaine des dérapages on
en a vu d'autres maxime livio et callao
des maires dans la tourmente après un
contrôle antidopage aux résultats
controversés
l'anc est toujours en cours sera
décisive pour confirmer ou pas la
qualification de l'équipe de france de
complet aux jo de 2016
côté organisation la france est loin
d'avoir fait l'unanimité positive au
haras du pin des bouchons à n'en plus
finir
à tel point que certains ont préféré
terminer à pied voilà nous reste un
petit peu de chemin à parcourir avant
d'arriver à l'heure qu'il est quand on
va arriver là-bas à 14h alors qu'on est
parti de chez nous à 8 heures du matin
pas mieux pour la dernière étape du
concours complet il a fallu convoyer
tous les chevaux jusqu'à d'ornano pour
l'épreuve du csto et là aussi les
mauvaises surprises se sont succédé
l'accès aux navettes les stands de
restauration et même les toilettes ont
posé problème
on a souvent entendu parler des jeux de
1994 à la et en hollande qui a été
épouvantable
hélas les journalistes landais se
réjouissent par sub finalement séjour en
france au concours immerseel
contrairement aux professionnels de la
presse les professionnels du commerce
eux sont ravis
cette quinzaine a rendu les affaires
florissantes et se dire que les affaires
sont plutôt bonnes oui rabah noël
beaucoup d'étrangers qui viennent et à
la famille ya même les gens qui
participent nobel qui sont des nouvelles
aussi qui viennent là on se retrouve et
qu'on se balader ya du monde soudain
dans la ville du monde en ville mais
aussi du beau monde au village des jeux
on a pu y croiser quelques people comme
charles berling qui a fait un détour par
mon plateau ou encore l'acteur
réalisateur guillaume canet l'un des
ambassadeurs de ces mondiaux
gros succès également de la scène
musicale avec le passage remarqué de
kool and the gang
on termine avec quelques coups de coeur
comme le horse ball qui a fait vibrer le
public pendant quatre jours à saint lô
le reining a conquis les coeurs avec son
show à l'américaine
la voltige a déchaîné les passions au
zénith
quant à la cérémonie d'ouverture elle en
a mis plein la vue aux 20000 spectateurs
présents au stade d'ornano des pleurs
des rires des émotions des petits couacs
aussi mais un public un public
fantastique qui est venu nombreux 560
5000 personnes sont venues ici assistait
ces jeux équestres mondiaux et puis vous
avez été très nombreux aussi à nous
suivre sur france télévisions et on en
est très fier de dire on va parler du
des podiums quand même parce que grâce à
cette médaille d'or décrochée tout à
l'heure la finale à quatre de saut
d'obstacles par le néerlandais jeroen
dubbeldam et bien les pays-bas passe en
deuxième position la grande bretagne est
donc le grand vainqueur de ces jeux
équestres mondiaux en normandie avec 15
médailles dont 5 en or les pays bas
arrivent juste derrière avec 6 médailles
afin 18 médailles dont 6 en or derrière
c'est l'allemagne avec cinq médailles
d'or 15 médailles au total et la france
est bien de terminer 6e ce qui est pas
mal du tout avec
six médailles une en or 4 en argent et
une en bronze
c'est très complet c'est c'est pas si
mal pour la france oui vu la pression
mais gare au pays hôte c'est une très
bon résultat c'est tellement difficile
de gagner à lexington avait terminé 10e
la france comme la deuxième place des
pays bas dans ces jeux équestres qui va
ce devant l'allemagne ça c'est
historique
oui les pays-bas s'installe durablement
parmi les très grandes nations des
sports équestres vêtements on voit
toujours la grande bretagne l'allemagne
trusté les épaules des meilleures places
mais effectivement les pays bas
deviennent de plus en plus forts de plus
en plus compétitif et ça c'est du temps
une nouveauté dans les sports équestres
à l'oral en talons on va peut-être
partir au stade d'ornano maintenant où
on voit que la cérémonie de clôture
vient de commencer et emilie elle a
commencé d'une façon assez particulière
il faut bien le dire que ce ne sont pas
les chevaux là qui sautent les obstacles
mais des hommes
laissons-les en semaine au personnel
team horse man tilt dartmann team
c'est une équipe internationale de
jeunes qui sautent des obstacles et
casse mais sans chevaux et avec beaucoup
d'humour il faut bien dire l'ours martin
qui compte 300 spectacles à son actif
ils ont voyagé dans 50 pays et
aujourd'hui sur la piste 15 sauteurs le
couple a été créée en en france 1 en
2005 et aujourd'hui c'est donc un groupe
international
ils se prennent pas au sérieux ils ont
des petits noms matteo claire abbas
barbie et paulo et regardez on rigole
mais c'est quand même assez incroyable
là ils sont quand même à peu prêt à
mettre 30
un sport de jeunes filles du sida c'est
quand même oui c'est un pas si mal ces
sportifs
c'est la crise l'auditionner
un choix qui a une fille dans le groupe
1 ouais on l'a pas repéré encore non moi
il ya une fille dans les antilles mais
qui saute plus haut que les garçons ça
ça me plaît bien anthony je suis pas sûr
qu'elle saute plus haut que le garçon a
le soutien de 40 dans les informations
je vais vous avez dit qu'il souhaitait
un attentat les garçons mais ils n'ont
pas leur maximum encore ils sont là pour
distraire le public et ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'il ya près d'un
siècle les sports équestres ont été
inventés pour distraire les publics en
cadre de l'épreuve physique anémique
plus sérieuse où on évalue être des
chevaux attelés c'est à ces rouleaux
effectivement comme un nouveau on est
court et on revisite les activités
humaines autour du cheval
ça permet de digérer un peu la médaille
d'argent de la voix quand même parce qu
on était quand même très gentils comme
vice champion du monde nous voilà les
espaces beaucoup d'humour je ne sais pas
c'était pas prévu savons que scénario
qui servit pictures qui se déshabille
comme ça si moi je sais peut-être pour
ça qu'on nous a rien dit c'est peut-être
pour ça que nous a rien dit tout cas un
spectacle qui s'adresse au public
féminin du stade d'ornano
regardez chaunu qui fait de l'humour
rechercher une fille
une double leur voiture pour faire ça sa
balle lot
regardez ils mentent et bars de plus en
plus haut oui c'est un réel exploit
sport ça permet de là devant nous à
l'image on a le l'archange mont saint
michel
quand j'ai été impressionné par la voter
à la fois des parcours de frédéric
cottier aussi de par la beauté des
illustrations des objets qui ont été
présentés quel bel hommage à la
normandie alors je crois qu'on va les
retrouver korrigans rose est quitte avec
ea non on attend de voir d'une minute
alors l'entraîneur le soutien de cette
équipe de france philippe guerdat bongo
savait y sont quand même étonnant c'est
alors que manu team je dois regarder
tout ça avec beaucoup d'attention en
ligne mais je crois que je préfère les
chevaux mottaki
n'empêche qu'ils montent encore les bars
etc franchement moi je crois que corinne
bien rosa là dessus avec des balles sans
fil des photos de tous les temps vide
avaient tous les chevaux qui la fait
vivre en main ses chevaux trouver vite
les sensations pour les maîtriser et
donc remporté aujourd'hui cette médaille
d'or de venir que je champion du monde
aurait dit nadal sont de rester un peu
c'est ce qu'il a voulu dire à jérôme de
belles dames faut quand même souligner
que hier il partait en disant 12e
position il a fait donc une remontée
exceptionnelle pour arriver gagner à la
première place du podium
et pendant ce temps là le horseman team
bike continuent de sauter des obstacles
de plus en plus haut on est presque en
haut des chandeliers on doit être
je dirais pas loin du but 60 absolument
je sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est ce
que vous aimez lire quand nous faisait
du sport français brille comme ça il va
y derrière et regarder qui sait qu'il
nous a rejoints sur ce plateau sont
souples à je regarde mes copains ils
sont à pied leur semaine voilà
andré-jacques le couple notre consultant
le speaker du cso vous revenez juste du
stade en a nous avait commenté l'accord
un peu mieux mais il a battu fort c'est
oui oui et on s'est mordu la langue
grande passer à l'antenne parce que
comme un rat tellement on a eu mal au
coeur j'ai la grèce de la chronométrie
et là où elle a garé sa voiture
si beaucoup 43 centièmes alors
totalement de poursuivre avec vous et
andré-jacques on allait rejoindre
corinne qui avec philippe gardaz
l'entraîneur sélectionneur de cette
équipe de france de saut d'obstacles
philippe à ce que ce soir vous êtes
sélectionneur comblé même 1
c'est difficile de répondre par
l'affirmative comme jase là dire je suis
satisfait pour être comblé en or et le
champion du monde au moins ou pas
expliqué pauline ville deux mois deux
fois l'argent alors ce formidable ici
deux manches public dénonce justement
avec une telle ferveur c'est sûr qu'on a
envie d'atteindre le sommet puisse enfin
on sait bien que c'est la première
classe malheureusement même si elle a
été fantastique qui donne la semaine on
échoué deux fois en rien et le sentiment
est partagé avec à chaque fois
oui mais bon c'est ça qui fait la
différence entre les titres et 2e place
à la fin on sait que l'histoire est
vraie ce que les titres donc je suis
satisfait bien sûr parce que tout le
monde a bien travaillé tout le staff
c'est bien beau la fédération j'entends
ce mot des cons
aucun semaine où vous attendiez pas
forcément ce résultat non mais l'appétit
gronde il vient en mangeant et puis
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui
j'étais plus optimiste que le premier
jour à coup aujourd'hui je me disais bon
l'été deuxième regret parce qu'on va
parler ou l'inde
alors je pense qu'arriver en tout cas
positif tout de même se faire la fête ce
soir je reviens mais je dois aller
préparer mes bagages je dois partir à
callian et de bain pour rejoindre mon
équipe là bas puisque j'en passe ici p
toute la semaine à concours hippique on
nous annonce de la neige
donc j'en aurais sûrement une semaine
compliquée avec une coupe des nations
samedi prochain
merci en tout cas c'est vers cette garde
a effectivement les plannings sont très
chargé pour ces cavaliers de haut niveau
et pour leur entraîneur andré jacques
andré jacques comment vous savez qui
c'est tout à l'heure tous temps au
dernier étage du stade d'ornano
comme je je vois toutes les interviews
et les interviews qu'on l'a fait déjà
cet hommage qui est rendu par tout le
monde au public ça me touche vraiment
parce qu'ils ont été merveilleux c'est
apprendre mon métier c'est voilà c'est
trente ans aussi de travailler avec eux
de d'éducation de d'esprit et et ils ont
été malades il n'y a pas un cavalier une
nation qui n'est pas été porté en
triomphe quand elle et quand elle est
entrée donc si déjà la normandie peu
fier de sa chef quant à la quant aux
sports ben voilà que comme vous c'est 43
centièmes de secondes c'est le sport il
n'a pas fait tomber une barre en double
dames et champion du monde il n'a pas
fait tomber une barre il y avait quatre
monstres vraiment de les créations du 6e
hier sam on n'a jamais vu une finale à
cadencer josé casque aussi équilibré
avec vraiment des cavaliers qui m'a un
peu tous le même parcours qui monte des
centaines de chevaux qui sont très
respectueux tout à fait j'ai une pensée
pour olga et à la rigueur il méritait
pas ça c'est on l'appelle le professeur
120 mètres il a monté des milliers des
milliers de chevaux mais c'est le sport
c'est ça cette finale cette finale
tournante et puis une autre énorme
pensée pour denise robert delaveau et et
le frère de stéphane lé frère le patri
stéphane qui nous a quittés il ya quatre
mois
ça a été pour les delaveau une année
voilà ce sont des histoires etc ou deux
médailles d'argent même sac
en tout cas il ya une ambiance dans ce
stade pendant toute cette semaine et
c'est en partie grâce à vous aussi andré
joie que j'ai assisté hier aux épreuves
je vous ai vu mettre l'ambiance dans le
stade ça fait beaucoup au spectacle et
voilà il fallait qu'on le dise aussi
s'il a recommandé le contraire
aujourd'hui c'est de voir tout ça il a
fallu leur demander le contraire
aujourd'hui on a pendant 10 minutes j'ai
essayé de leur expliquer de leurs biens
leur montrer le le sas les chevaux qui
allait être là la pression énorme que
pouvait apporter de plus et ils ont été
à la fois très chaleureux et à la fois
d'être toujours un oeil sur les chevaux
dès qu'il en a qui touche un petit plomb
santé non bravo je suis vraiment très
très fier de tous les publics de ces
jeux équestres mondiaux j'ai vu au haras
du pin je les ai vus à voltiger vue
pendant le reining j'ai vu je pense que
sur l'hippodrome j'ai pas pu y aller de
sa devait être merveilleux aussi déjà
qui a cette faculté de transmettre une
émotion une connaissance d'un sport avec
ses règles ses techniques les contrats
de fouler les observe et verticaux
comment aussi aujourd'hui à travers
cette finale à quatre comment en un
temps très contraint comment chaque
cavalier doit apprendre sa nouvelle
monture et je rends fectivement hommage
en irak pour pour sa passion et pour sa
grande connaissance du monde du cheval
il ne serait qu il le fait avec beaucoup
de sincérité on peux vous l'assurer nous
si on va retourner chez vous la
banaliser la zorn le croisement entre le
16 mai puis le zèbre et le cheval oui
concours de saut d'obstacles il y en a
qui font du concours hippique aux
étasuniens et brûlent way et si c'est
une femelle elle s'appelle stormy elle
est née en 1997 aux états unis elle a 17
ans elle est stérile comme la plupart
des des animaux hybrides et l arrêté d
et brûle de son père tout son caractère
sauvage
d'ailleurs son premier propriétaire
n'arrivait pas le domestique et on
aurait dû lui envoyer de patrice
delaveau c'est exactement la cible sûrs
qu'ils étaient inventées pour lutter
contre la mouche tsé-tsé ball d'histoire
la russie regardez elle a quand même
gardé un petit et instinct sauvage mais
un garde et emmanuel chez nous ça fait
des zébrures andré jacques jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout ne vous laissera pas cette
force
elle a été confiée à près de pirelli un
chuchoteur spécialiste du dressage et
aux logiques et est lui-même la confia
son élève australien andy bouffe c'est
lui qui est avec elle la sur la piste
qu'on connaît bien haut niveau ça passe
qui est installé en france un nom il y
aura de la cense dans les yvelines en
pratique l'éthologie l'art du
comportement du cheval exactement du
comportement du fal et et de comment se
comporter avec les chevaux aussi pour
mieux c'est et ça révolutionne aussi
beaucoup de traditions
et peut-être de changer le rapport entre
l'homme de challes de le passer d'une
espèce de domination il ya encore un
certain nombre d'années jusqu'à vraiment
une collaboration et une complicité et
andy booth pour regagner la confiance de
stormy il a commencé par passer huit
jours complets avec elle squatte sans
rien faire nuitée jour juste pour
l'habituer l'a observé l'homme qui
murmurait à l'oreille des chevaux c'est
on parle on parle de cette philosophie
en fait il faut savoir que cette force
est capable aujourd'hui de réaliser les
mêmes exercices qu'un cheval elle
connaît les exercices de dressage de
basse écoles comme les pôles en dedans
les appuyer elle est aussi capable de
sauter des petits cavaletti des petits
des multiples obstacles et même qu'elle
peut jouer au football
ouais c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on dit
moi j'ai vu des gens j'en ai vu un sauté
aux états unis à washington pendant le
winter
je suis un festival sur les épreuves
under water donc des épreuves de style
où on saute mais on est noté aussi sur
les si le style du sénat listings à
l'aise derrière ses skis à former tous
les cavaliers américains qui est domine
qui font partie des meilleurs du monde
actuellement ils sont tous passés par
par ce registre du de l'équitation
hunter soigner leur attitude leur
position leur place avec le cheval
regardez comme elle est belle selon
avait passé en france voilà dites-le ce
que nos nos enseignants devrait devrait
systématiquement appliquée et andy booth
je pense va monter sur cette offre
devrait nous faire une démonstration ça
doit pas évident il ya quand même 20
mille personnes dans ce stade
qu'est-ce qui lui a murmuré à l'oreille
pour l'habituer à vingt huit personnes
j'aimerais savoir temps on l'a sorti de
sa retraite exprès pour cette cérémonie
de clôture à 16 heures salle n attendant
revendique également une baisse des
jours paisibles en normandie
comment il s'appelle des jours paisibles
en normandie comment s'appelle-t-elle
dormi chez sita endormi tout un
programme
regardez et elle accepte andy booth sur
son dos alors vous avez vu c'est un
licol éthologique
y'a pas de il n'y a pas de morts dans la
bouche de cet or ce fait c'est juste le
le poids la pression sur le champ prin
et il utilise que les américains
appellent la même angoisse terre l'année
traîne la reine de coûts mais c'est
juste bleus le poids de la reine sur
l'encolure utilisant en reining
d'ailleurs exactement ketting c'est
parce que l'équitation américaine est
une équitation d'ordre et non de
contacts donc vous demander l'ordre
quand vous voulez vous arrêter vous
lever un petit peu les mains vous tendez
que nous relâcher tout de suite parce
que si on ne relâche et peuvent
continuer à tendre le cheval va se
battre à recullé quand vous serrez vos
gens vous pressez vos jantes vous
acceleo changer d'alluré mais si vous
voulez relâcher si vous restez avec les
gens me contactent ça veut dire pour le
cheval ont continué à accélérer
équitation d'ordre qui à côté de stormy
jument à côté effectif dumas côté jument
grise ici dément entre un dessin pour
voir dréjac je règlerai vous allez voir
partir une belle collection de dessins
c'est bien caricaturer de quoi faire cet
benneteau n'a pas marché exactement noël
il a changé oublier ma tondeuse
aujourd'hui
on peut rappeler quelqu'un qui les
touchent aux mais c'est la fin quand je
vais vous quittez c'est terrible pour
moi
or ce blues nous guette or ce blues très
bon sens et blues nouvelle discipline of
blues et la semaine prochaine va être
dur pour nous tous un jack
qu'est ce que vous allez faire la
semaine prochaine dormir non vendent des
chevaux vente des chevaux au micro
comics que je pars à une parabole droit
pour fermer 27/28 d'entre eux enchaînent
fait tu savais que tous les éleveurs
sont déjà bonnes parties parti à
fontainebleau puisque a débuté la grande
semaine de l'élevage non pour les
finales des trois ans des quatre ans des
cinq ans dès 6 ans c'est à dire ses
chevaux qui vont bien peut-être oui pour
les 6 ans pourquoi pas dans quatre ans
être à bromont pour les jeux équestres
mondiaux 2018 au québec
donc tous les éleveurs de france ainsi
que les éleveurs du monde je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont venus ici
aux jeux équestres mondiaux vont rester
une semaine de plus
parce que je crois que les chevaux
français en particulièrement séduit
également tout au long de cette
quinzaine et ont montré qu'on avait
absolument aucun complexe à avoir
vis-à-vis des autres has been a
visiblement des hollandais des belges il
a dit ardeurs de nouveau monté pas
sandra retard en concours complet a mis
aussi un secret assez que les
projecteurs sur sur les chevronnés en
basse-normandie et bien sûr et le 2
donc encore un petit coup de chapeau à
la famille dernier aux eric il l'a fait
naître mais le nombre de chevaux
français monte aussi par des cavaliers
étrangers tout au long de ces jeux
mondiaux que ce soit en complet que ce
soit en saut d'obstacles il avait
également dans les dents certains
attelage prouve qu'on n'a aucun complexe
à avoir et donc les meilleurs chevaux
des générations le 4 5 et 6 ans donc des
futurs athlètes sont à fontainebleau
toute la semaine pour la grande semaine
de l'élevage et chaque soir on se
retrouve à voir le roi chez marcel
rozier qu'on a reçu ici
l'antenne pour vendre et proposer au
monde et a beaucoup d'étrangers environ
300 chevaux de 3 ans des plénières et
les petits plein de l'année dont une
fille de krach boom qui était le cheval
avec kevin staut a été champion d'europe
en 2009 à windsor
j'en ai passé beaucoup de choses tout au
long des deux semaines ici en normandie
sur les pistes bien sûr mais on viens de
l'entendre avec vous aussi autour des
pistes beaucoup de discussions beaucoup
de rencontres nous ml on a passé en tout
cas deux excellentes semaines d'émotions
des grands moments
oui le losc blues doug est effectivement
et on voudrait donner un grand un grand
merci aux équipes de france et en
normandie et au team hf2 de france de
voile a regardé par la ji ils sont
cachés vous les voyez pas mais je peux
vous dire qu'ils ont fait un sacré
travail voilà ils sont tous là autour du
réalisateur jean françois clerc il ya
aussi loïc le marchand qui est passé
cette semaine qui a réalisé les journaux
c'était vraiment une belle expérience
travailler avec que pendant quinze jours
et on est très heureux et ça va nous
manquer et le mélange de pluie l'équipe
de france 3 basse-normandie
et de france télévisions c'est vrai que
c'est un grand moment aussi pour nous on
a passé des très bons jeux on est très
heureux d'avoir présenté ses émissions
ensemble mélismes un plaisir infini on a
réunifié
la normandie est la première écoute on
fera peut-être une émission un jour
aussi la saint michel une émission de
cheval pourquoi pas ça donne des idées
voilà un mois et s'était paré saint
andré direct vous dites et je leur ai ça
va faire le haras du pin ça va être
horrible
merci à linthal ont souvent merci à vous
andré jacq
merci à vous non vraiment et la grand
merci à vous et manuel je vais revivre
retour voir ces quinze jours formidables
sur internet sur internet et puis encore
le journal de france 3 basse-normandie
tout à l'heure il s'agit aussi demain et
on voit aussi le bilan des jeux on en
reparlera encore dans les semaines qui
suivent
et puis je voudrais dire merci aux
cavaliers aux chevaux voilà aux chevaux
n'empêche qu'ils nous ont donné mille
plus de 1000 chevaux que nous donnait un
formidable spectacle pendant quinze
jours on se quitte sur de belles images
merci beaucoup à vous merci beaucoup de
nous avoir suivi et à très bientôt on
espère bientôt